et on va revenir sur une enquête
tentaculaire révélée il y a peu et qui
vient toucher depuis plusieurs mois le
milieu du porno français une affaire qui
dépasse le fait divers parce qu'elle
traite des abus d'une industrie qui pèse
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
on en parle avec vous aujourd'hui Diane
Hervé je suis pas bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau et vous Lucile
pierre mon bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être toutes les deux sur ce
plateau vous êtes toutes les deux
avocates et vous défendez des femmes
victimes de ce dossier qu'on a baptisé
l'affaire [__] du nom d'une pratique
pornographique qui regroupe en réalité
plusieurs affaires peut-être d'abord
pour celles et ceux qui nous regardent
et qui ne sont pas familiers de
l'affaire on peut essayer de la résumer
en quelques mots oui alors l'affaire
l'affaire French boukake c'est la
première enquête d'une telle ampleur qui
vient enquêter les pratiques de violence
systématique qui se déroulent
aujourd'hui dans le milieu du porno
qu'on appelle amateur français
et puis également une affaire Jacquie et
Michel qui à L2
Vienne investiguer des pratiques qui
jusque là étaient largement passées sous
les radars des services d'enquêtes et de
police alors cette affaire à plusieurs
mois elle a été révélée récemment dans
des articles dans la presse on parle
d'un système quasi industriel de traite
d'être humain de femmes en général de en
l'occurrence de femmes assez jeunes ou
le proxénét le proxénétisme se mêlent au
viol et au chantage financier et ça a
remonter les questions effectivement il
y a deux affaires en réalité il y a une
première affaire French boukake qui a
été initié à la suite de la découverte
du site internet French boukake par des
enquêteurs qui surveillaient les réseaux
Internet il y a une deuxième affaire qui
dite Jacquie et Michel qui est plus
récente et qui concerne plus
spécialement le site internet en
question l'effet qui sont aujourd'hui
poursuivis sont effectivement des faits
à la fois de viol de proxénétisme et de
traite d'êtres humains euh dans son
victime un certain nombre de jeunes
femmes une cinquantaine pour le dossier
French boukake effectivement on se rend
compte que les violences sont quasi
systématique dans les vidéos
pornographiques qui sont aujourd'hui
diffusées le rapport parlementaire qui a
été récemment publié par quatre
sénatrices le 29 septembre dernier
donne comme information que près de 90%
des vidéos qui sont aujourd'hui
diffusées sur Internet contiennent des
violences faites aux femmes
alors on va revenir dans un instant sur
ce sur ce rapport parlementaire donc ce
dont on parle ce sont des femmes des
jeunes femmes parfois des étrangères qui
se retrouvent prises dans un engrenage
et voilà qui se retrouve malgré malgré
elle bien sûr dans des situations
catastrophiques c'est exactement ça
l'enquête a permis de mettre à jour un
système très organisé de recrutement de
ces femmes qui évidemment ne sont pas
des actrices
professionnelles de films
pornographiques ce sont de très jeunes
femmes qui sont ciblées et qui sont
repérés pour leur situation de grande
vulnérabilité économiques psychologiques
affective ce sont souvent des femmes qui
sont assez isolées et le procédé qui a
été mis en lumière par l'enquête c'est
qu'un un rabatteur qui se faisait passer
pour une femme et qui cherchait à
devenir au fil des mois leur confidente
et leur ami leur proposait via les
réseaux sociaux sur lesquels il les
contactait d'abord la pratique
banalisée d'escortings en utilisant un
vocabulaire
très très édulcoré et recouvrant pas du
tout la réalité avec une première
expérience d'escortings qui consistait
en réalité en un viol de soumission afin
de faire tomber les barrières
psychologiques de ces femmes une
expérience assez dure pendant à la suite
de laquelle les femmes n'étaient jamais
réglées ce qui les plaçait dans une
situation financière à nouveau plus
difficile et permettait aux rabatteur en
question de les amener vers la
proposition de tournage de scène à
caractère pornographique leur indiquant
à tort que ces scènes ne seraient pas
diffusées en France et étaient destiné à
une clientèle privée ou un client privé
à l'étranger les femmes réalisées au
moment d'arriver sur les lieux de
tournage que ce qui leur avait été
présenté n'était évidemment pas la
réalité et était soumise à des pratiques
extrêmement violentes et extrêmement
dégradante avant que les vidéos
diffuser sur toutes les plateformes que
nous connaissons et surtout les surtout
les sites Internet accessibles en France
que nous connaissons
la vie la vie personnelle la vie
familiale la vie professionnelle de ces
femmes s'effondraient souvent à ce
moment-là puisque plus d'une victime a
perdu son emploi rompu ses relations
avec sa famille avec ses cercles de
relations amicales et intervenez ensuite
l'engrenage du chantage au retrait des
vidéos dans lesquelles les producteurs
mis en examen sont aujourd'hui accusés
d'avoir
imposé aux femmes de verser des sommes
très importantes pour obtenir ou ne même
pas obtenir le retrait de ces vidéos
voilà on parle de vidéos donc dont
certaines sont des viols déguisées qui
ont été vus des millions de fois oui on
compte en France aujourd'hui plus de 137
millions de visionnages de ces vidéos
pornographiques de manière générale les
victimes aujourd'hui qui savent que ces
vidéos sont publiées sont
systématiquement remises face au viol
ils ont subi elles revivent
systématiquement les violences extrêmes
qu'elles ont subi comme disait ma conso
les violences sont les faits sont
absolument effrayables et ces vidéos
sont diffusées de manière extrêmement
large en France mais aussi par tous dans
le monde ce qui porte une atteinte au
droit humain extrêmement importante
assez victime voilà les attentes en haut
droit de ces femmes en fait sont ce
s'additionnent les les unes aux autres
quoi donc des femmes forcées à accepter
des pratiques extraordinairement
dégradantes vous le disiez pour
certaines forcés de payer pour
soi-disant récupérer ses vidéos qu'en
réalité elle ne pour certaines d'entre
jamais récupérer vous défendez toutes
les deux plusieurs de ces plaignantes
sans trop dévoiler des secrets de
l'instruction comment vont-elles
aujourd'hui
elles sont dans une situation qui est
extrêmement extrêmement difficile ce
sont des femmes qui ont été choisies à
l'origine pour leur situation de
fragilité économique affective familiale
pour ce qui concerne la plaignante que
j'assiste à la suite de les diffusion
des vidéos elle a perdu son emploi et
elle a et elle a vu son cercle de
relation amicale se détournaient d'elle
aujourd'hui ça reconstruction est très
freinée par la difficulté que nous avons
à obtenir le retrait des vidéos puisque
c'est un c'est un enjeu majeur dans ce
dossier Lucile Piermont vous l'indiquez
à l'instant pour pour les personnes que
nous assistons être à la merci d'une
réapparition de ces vidéos c'est une
souffrance psychologique et une angoisse
psychologique qui est très importante et
malheureusement un certain nombre de
sites ne permettent pas le retrait de
ces vidéos donc la situation de de nos
clientes elle est encore aujourd'hui
très difficile et c'est là pour autant
qu'il y a peut-être une première partie
de réappropriation c'est que l'enquête
qui est inédite on le rappelle dans son
par son l'ampleur a été ouverte suite à
une plainte en 2020 donc une femme qui a
osé parler donc aujourd'hui on recense
une cinquantaine de victimes présumées
une quinzaine d'hommes je crois que
c'est que des hommes des acteurs des
producteurs des réalisateurs qui sont
poursuivis ou impliqués l'instruction
est en cours est-ce qu'il y aura
d'autres d'autres arrestations d'autres
mises en examen l'enquête est toujours
en cours et contenue de l'ampleur des
faits et du nombre de victimes il y a
effectivement des actes d'instructions
qui doivent encore être effectués c'est
pourquoi on a aujourd'hui pas encore de
clôture de l'enquête et le procès se
tiendra plus tard quand on aura fini de
d'investiguer sur ces effets et il est
très important pour les victimes que
justement tous les faits soient
investigués et que se présente devant la
cour d'assises un dossier qui permette
d'entrer en votre condamnation
s'agissant de fait extraordinairement
grave et violent l'effet dont on parle
c'est quoi c'est traite d'être humain
alors la traite d'être tendance à
désigne le fait de recruter des
personnes au sein de les exploiter en
l'occurrence à des faits de viol et de
proxénétisme donc ce sont ces
pratiques-là qui sont qui sont
interrogées aujourd'hui l'affaire nous
plonge dans les rouages d'une industrie
low cost dont la matière première ce
sont ces jeunes femmes précisément alors
elle questionne cette industrie qui
n'est théoriquement pas illégale que
celle du porno amateur mais qu'Internet
est venu complètement bouleverser
exactement c'est en fait la difficulté à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés c'est
que l'apparition des des plateformes de
diffusion qu'on appelle des tubes est
venu bouleverser le modèle économique de
l'industrie pornographique française et
mondiale
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est de produire
un nombre suffisant de contenu qui
puisse être diffuser de façon gratuite
et des contenus qui génèrent du clic
puisque YouTube ou pornhub vivent sur
pardon youporn youporn hub
tire leur revenu du trafic généré par
ces vidéos on est donc confronté à un
besoin de la matière première
effectivement de jeunes femmes qui ne
sont pas des actrices professionnelles
et qui accepteraient de tourner des
vidéos qui seraient présentées comme du
porno amateur d'où le système de
recrutement qui a été mis en place et
effectivement le fait qu'il y ait plus
de modèles économique et qu'on est
beaucoup moins aujourd'hui d'actrices
professionnelles
implique des tournages à très bas coût
sans aucune protection et sans aucun
égard pour les personnes qui sont
impliquées dans ces dans ces tournages
ça pose la question de la production de
ces vidéos mais aussi au bout de la
chaîne de qui les regarde et qui
cliquent effectivement alors vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure la classe politique
s'est emparée du sujet il y a eu un
rapport rendu public à la fin du mois de
septembre par une délégation au droit
des femmes du Sénat qui a estimé je la
cite que la lutte contre les violences
systémiques envers les femmes générées
par l'industrie pornographique devait
devenir une priorité de politique
publique et pénale comment est-ce que
cet industrie peut être mieux encadré
aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs solutions
qui ont été proposées par le rapport
parlementaire qui a été rendu il y a
évidemment des solutions qui sont
prenaient par l'industrie pornographique
elle-même et qui repose sur un
encadrement législatif et sur la mise en
place de Chartres de bonne conduite sur
les tournages le il y a d'autres
notamment les associations certaines
associations qui prônent elles pour un
une abolition plus récente de la
pornographie afin d'éviter ce type ce
système et les types de déviance qu'on a
retrouvé dans le la pornographie et qui
sont mises en exergue dans les deux
dossiers 10 French boukake et Jacquie et
Michel
oui et ce qui est évidemment essentiel
également c'est la question de l'accès
des mineurs à la pornographie puisqu'on
sait qu'aujourd'hui la grande majorité
des enfants de moins de 12 ans et a
fortiori de moins de 15 ans ont été
exposées de façon volontaire ou non à
des images pornographiques et on sait
que c'est une problématique de santé
publique car on sait que le fait d'être
exposé à des images aussi violent un âge
aussi jeune à d'importantes
répercussions sur la façon dont on
construit son son identité sexuelle et
ses rapports sexuels et affectifs futurs
quand on sait que la pornographie
aujourd'hui véhicule les stéréotypes les
plus racistes et les plus en vrai on
comprend facilement le fait que ce soit
une préoccupation majeure des
responsables politiques et un véritable
problème de santé publique pour pour nos
générations donc il y a parallèlement
voilà la poursuite de cette enquête qui
débouchera vous le disiez sans doute sur
un procès donc on le rappelle pour
l'instant une quinzaine de personnes qui
sont poursuivies ou impliquées une
cinquantaine peut-être plus de victimes
qui se sont déclarés à ce stade
peut-être plus et puis parallèlement
donc ce travail politique pour essayer
de mieux encadrer cet industrie porno on
le rappelle qui pèse des centaines de
millions d'euros et pas qu'en France
merci à toutes les deux mettre bien
Hervé je suis pain et Lucile Piermont
d'être venu ce matin nous parler de
cette affaire c'est